[موسيقى]
عرف الاديب والصحفي المصري احمد بهجت صاحب
الكتاب الشهير قصص الحيوان في القران
بكتاباته الساخره اللاذعه والمهذبه اعد
على مدى 30 عاما البرنامج الاذاعي الشهير
كلمتين وبس الذي كان يقدمه الفنان فؤاد
المهندس على اذاعه البرنامج العام من
القاهره وكان ينتقد فيه الكثير من سلبيات
المجتمع والدوله من طرائف ما يروى عن احمد
بهجت رحمه الله ان عنزا من الماعز اكلت
بعض كتبها فكتب مقالا ساخرا يتهم فيه
العنزه بمحاربه الفكر
في اليوم التالي على نشر المقال اشتكاه
عند المسؤولين عشر شخصيات اعتقد كل منهم
انه هو العنز في قصه احمد بهجت الى
العناوين
هل ظهرت معجزه نبويه جديده في مكه المكرمه
قيس سعيد في المقاهي والتونسيون في الشارع
100 جنيه فقط غرامه رشق ملك بريطانيا
ببيضه
نازحوا مخيمات القهر والصقيع السوريه
يستغيثون
قصه شيرين عبد الوهاب مع حذاء الجيش
اللبناني
نائبه بحرينيه تبحث عن وظيفه مناسبه
لشكلها
هل ينضب حكم الظفر الى لجنه امير الشعراء
[موسيقى]
صور نشرتها حسابات سعوديه حكوميه توثق
جبال مكه وقد غطت برداء عصبيا في مشهد
بديع ومبهر وظاهره نادره في هذه المنطقه
القاحله مرحبا لم يتوقف التقاط هذه الصور
وغيرها عن الحله الجديده لجبال مكه
المكرمه على عدسات المصورين بل تم التقاطه
المشهد ايضا بابعاد علميه ودينيه اكد معها
الخبراء ان جزيره العرب ستتحول طبيعتها
وان تغير قادم لا محاله بل ان علماء اكدوا
ان الخليج سيخضر فيما الجفاف قد حضر الى
اوروبا والارض التي تجف
تتصحرؤه الى ان التغيرات ستعم الجزيره
العربيه باكملها وان الربع الخالي الذي
سمي كذلك لخلوه من الحياه لم يبقى خالي
بعد اليوم فالامطار والسيول التي اجتاحت
في الاونه الاخيره بدات تحيه وتبعث الحياه
فيك والتغيرات الجذريه قادمه لمحل في
مواجهه التفسيرات العلميه يرى البعض ان
معجزه نبويه شريفه بدات بالظهور في مكه
واكنافها لان الرسول محمد صلى الله عليه
وسلم اخبر قبل اكثر من الف واربعمائه عام
ان جزيره العرب ستعود خضراء غداء والرسول
الكريم ليس عالما جغرافيا لكنه لا ينطق عن
الهواء ان هو الا وحي يوحى
كل شيء تردوه الى الدين هي متغيرات
جغرافيه ومناخيه قال احدهم فحاوره اخر
ونحن لا نقول الا كما تقول انها متغيرات
جغرافيه ومناخيه اخبر بها رسولنا عليه
الصلاه والسلام بينما وصف البعض تحقق
نبوءه الرسول الكريم اليوم بانها اعجاز
نبوي خاصه ان الصحراء كانت مروجا فعلا لكن
قبل ولادته صلى الله عليه وسلم با الاف
السنين
ما اخبر به النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم عن
حال جزيره العرب فانه قال لا تقوم الساعه
حتى تعود ارض العرب مروجا وانهارا والله
على كل شيء قدير هكذا يرى بعض الاخضرار
جزيره العرب القادمه لا محاله معجزه نبويه
شريفه وعلامه من علامات الساعه
رجل من تونس يقول بلا دونا كانت سباقه
بظهور علامه من علامات الساعه فيها وما هي
يا اخ يجيب الم يقول النبي صلى الله عليه
وسلم اذا وصل الامر الى غير اهله فانتظر
الساعه هنا تدخل بهيج وهي وقفت على تونس
يا حبيبي
من تونس العاصمه مشهد مرعب رئيس البلاد
قيس سعيد يزور المقاهي مع الكاميرات بدا
الشباب في احد الفيديوهات جالسين يتابعون
اللعب بينما الرئيس يلقي عليهم خطابا ولم
يستقبلوه بلياقه كما لم يودعوه فيما ظهر
احدهم في صوره موسم
مستغربا كلام الرئيس قيس الذي لا ينتهي عن
التاريخ وعن المستقبل
الوحيدون الذين وقفوا له في الصوره شباب
اسيويون كانوا موجودين داخل المقهى
دائما كبير
ان شاء الله اشوفكم بخير
وليس من الخيال عندما اشتكى صاحبنا من نقص
الحليب والسكر والقهوه عنده ليرد فخامه
الرئيس بان كل شيء متوفر لكن هناك من
يفتعل الازمه طيب بدل ما تيجي على القهوه
ابعت له اثنين كيلو قهوه علق احد الركاب
على متن السفينه حماها الله
كل شيء متوفي
الاوضاع مهما كان المقهى مجافيا للرئيس
فانه يبقى نعمه بالمقارنه مع الشارع تقول
الناس للرئيس لقد جعنا فيغضب الرئيس وقد
حق له ان يغضب فالرئيس اخي المواطن الجائع
ليس الشاف ايمن سمهود حتى يحضر لك طبخه
عندما تجوع
جول
[موسيقى]
وسط هذه الاجواء المكهربه بالبلتاز العالي
للرئيس كانت تونسيون يحيون ذكر ثوره
الياسمين
بارحل يا رئيس حشود وشعارات وسجلات مشهد
يعيد عقارب الزمن الى اثنا عشر سنه مضت
التونسيون يحيون ذكر الثوره والمعارضه
تحتجه وترفع شعارات المنوئه لسياسات
الرئيس سعيد كما حدث قبل 12 عاما يردد
تونسيون شعارات ذاتها
حريه ثوره ارحل وصفينا الرئيس قيس سعيد
بالديكتاتور
وهو لقب الناشط السياسي رضا المكي الموالي
لسعيد عنده شويه مشكله بالنظر كما يرى
البطيخ جانيريك خوخ صغير فاحصى الاف
المتظاهرين ضد سعيد باقل من 50
واحد في الشارع
طقس اليوم في فقد الشعبيه اليوم في
المقابل القياديه بالتيار الديمقراطي
ساميه عبده لديها راي مختلف جذريا راي
يجعلها خائنه للوطن في نظر سعيد
ته السياسيه لشان العام وفي رسم السياسه
العامه للدول يحاسب يحاسب وزير التجاره
يعني الدوله كبيره جدا عليه هو صغير جدا
على السكر
باستثناء يا اطراف قليله كحكومه البحرين
التي اوفدت الى تل ابيب وفدا امنيا التقى
المفوض العام لشرطه الاحتلال يكاد يجمع
العالم اليوم على ان حكومه نتنياهو
الحاليه هي اكثر الحكومات تطرفا في تاريخ
اسرائيل القصير ومع ذلك فان نتنياهو واجه
100,000 متظاهر في تل ابيب رفضا لحكومته
وسياساتها بكلمه واحده هذا خيار الناخبين
هذا الخيار الناخبين حجه بها رئيس الوزراء
الاسرائيلي بنيامين نتنياهو جلسه حكومته
للتاكيد على موضيه في خطته المثيره للجدل
داخل الجهاز القضائي وبعد يوم واحد على
خروج قرابه 100,000 اسرائيلي لاحتجاجه ضد
حكومه نتنياهو حكمه المحاكم البريطانيه
على الشاب العشريني هاري سبارتاكوس طيب
بدفع غرامه قدرها 100 جنيه استرليني اي
حوالي 120 دولارا امريكيا بسبب قيامه
الشهر الماضي برشقي بيضه في اتجاه الملك
تشاللز الثالث بريطانيا دوله مستعمره
فماذا عن الدول المستعمره قديش حق البيضه
فيها
طبعا نحن لا نريد ان يرفق احد حكام الشرق
بورده لكن تخيلوا لو ان هذه البيضه رشق
بها كيم جونغ اون مثلا ماذا كان سيحدث
للرافق واهله وعشيرته وابناء قريته
من حسن حظي ان الرفيق كم لا يشاهد هذا
البرنامج
[موسيقى]
اطمئنه لن تكون هناك حرب عالميه ثالثه
يهدد بها الرئيس الشيشاني رمضان قاديروف
بتاكيده ان زر نووي تحت اصابع بوتين لن
تقوم الحرب بضمانه بوليود ميرزلنسكي لان
اوكرانيا ستقف في وجهي روسيا يقول ذلك
فيما جنوده بداوا بتزييت الدبابات
السوفياتيه من مخلفات الحرب العالميه
اعاده تشغيل الدبابات سوفيتيه لاستخدامها
في حربهم ضد روسيا والمشكله الاكبر مع
سخونه الجبهات ان هذه الدبابه القديمه
بارده وتحتاج وقتا لتسخين محركاتها على
الجبهه الروسيه
حركه الصناعات العسكريه كما فعل في اجتماع
عبر الفيديو طلب خلاله من وزير الصناعه ان
لا يلعب دور الاحمق
لم تكتفي انقره وزير خارجي
بتنديد حكومه السويد بحادثه تعليق ما وصفت
بمجموعه كرديه دميه مقلوبه تصور الرئيس
التركي رجب طيب اردوغان في ستوكهولم معلقا
من قدميه بحبل في مشهد يرمز الى الاعداء
وفي طهران حذرت ايران الحكومه الفرنسيه من
رد حاسم بعد نشر مجله
رسوما مهينه للمرشد الاعلى السيد علي
خامني كتب وزير الخارجيه الايراني حسين
امير عبد الله عبر تويتر ان العمل المهين
وغير اللائق الذي بادرت اليه مجله فرنسيه
ضد المرجعيه السياسيه والدينيه
لن تمر دون رد حاسم وفعال واضاف لن نسمح
للحكومه الفرنسيه بتجاوز حدودها لكن
الحكومه الفرنسيه تتجاوزت حدودها بل كل
الحدود عندما شرعت اساءه المجله نفسها
شارلي ابدو لرسول الله محمد عليه واله
الصلاه والسلام وقد تولى الرئيس ايمانويل
ماكرون شخصيا مهمه الدفاع عن نشر الرسوم
المسيئه للرسول الكريم اما بالنسبه
للاساءه للرئيس اردوغان في السويد ففي
السويد نفسها اسيء ايضا للرسول الكريم صلى
الله عليه وسلم واستنكر تركيا والامه
الاسلاميه جمعاء الحادثه لكن دون التوصل
الى سن السويد واوروبا عموما قوانين تمنع
ازدراء الاديان فمن يسمح بمسبه نبيك يسقط
كل الحرمات التعبيريه عنه اقل شيء انه
يسمح بسب رئيسك
تنقل صحيفه وول ستريت جورنال عن رئيس
الوزراء العراقي محمد شياع السوداني
تاييده بقاء القوات الامريكيه في العراق
الى اجل غير مسمى بحسب وصف الصحيح
ذكرت صحيفه في تقريرنا سوداني الدافع
بوجود القوات الامريكيه للقضاء على ما
تبقى من تنظيم داعش ولم يحدث
صحيفه ان الحاجه لا تزال قائمه للقوات
الاجنبيه وان القضاء على داعش تحتاج الى
مزيد من الوقت منذ عده سنوات وايران
بدعم داعش بل هناك في ايران من يعتقد بان
قاسم سليمان احبط مشروع داعش الامريكي
ولهذا تم التصفيته علما ان نفوذ ايران في
حكومات عراق ما بعد البعث ليس مختلفا عليه
فكيف تدعم ايران العراق الذي يطالب ببقاء
القوات امريكيه للقضاء على داعش وايران
تعتبر داعش اداه بيد امريكا هز العالم هذا
الاسبوع فيديو من ولايه كاليفورنيا
الامريكيه اظهر صاحب معرض للوحات الفنيه
وهو يرش امراه مشرده عجوز بالماء البارد
وهي ترتجف وترجوه التوقف لكنه اصر على
طردها من امام متجر جيره في المقابل لا
يهتز شيء في هذا العالم عندما تستغيث
مسنات مخيمات القهر السوريه وتشكو البرد
والجوع والجوره والتهجير فهل من يلبي
النداء يا حكومات العرب والمسلمين من قطر
والخليج الى المشارق والمغارب الى كل ارض
فيها نظير لهن في الخلق او اخ في الدين
ابن الحته ابيعه
لا قصدي
انه النوم
كيف البرد بالليل
[موسيقى]
اشترت الرئاسه الموريتانيه طائره جديده
بقيمه 25 مليون دولار يقول التقرير فثار
الثائره الفقراء تجددون طائرتكم فخامه
الرئيس ونحن بالكاد نستطيع ان نجدد ابريق
الشاي في بيوتنا لكن هل يليقوا ان يهبط
الرئيس في العواصم بطائره اقل فخامه ان
ذلك يهدد سمعه البلاد وكرامتها التي لا
تهددها الامعاء الفارغه للفقراء يعلق
احدهم شراء طائره لرئاسه الجمهوريه في
موريتانيا بنحو 25 مليون دولار اشعل مواقع
التواصلي الاجتماعي فقط تبين ردود الفعل
بين من اعتبر الخطوه اهدارا للمال العام
وفي المقابل راى اخرون ان هذا الامر طبيعي
في معظم دول العالم المغنيه المصريه
زارت مؤخرا برفقه زوجها مخيم عين الحلوه
بلبنان للقاء المطرب فضل شاكر المطلوب
للسلطات اللبنانيه التي استدعت شيرين بسبب
هذه الزياره بعد ذلك وخلال حفله لها
بالكويت تقول شيرين على المسرح زياره بفضل
شاكر عزيزه على قلبي لكن حذاء الجيش
اللبناني على دماغي من فوق مدام شيرين
تشتري الجيوش الاحذيه البياده لجنودها لكي
يمشوا بها على الارض وليس على رؤوس اهلهم
اللبنانيون يحبون جيشهم يكرهون ميليشيات
الحرب لكن لا هم يقبلون ولا ابنائهم في
الجيش يقبلون ان توضع الاحذيه على رؤوسهم
نحن اسسنا جيشنا لنرفع رؤوسنا به وليس لي
يدعس على رؤوسنا
فرجاء شيرين لا تستخدم مثل هذه المصطلحات
الذليله على ابنائنا الاحرار تقول لك سيده
لبنانيه
[موسيقى]
لكن كمان
ضباط او بياده الجيش اللبناني على دماغي
من فوق
هذه الحركه
في مسلسل للموت راها لبعض غير مناسبه
للدرام العربيه وانتقدها هو مقطع عابر في
عمل تمثيليه لكن ماذا لو تحولت هذه الحركه
الى طريقتي كلام دائما لاحدى المذيعات
ههه
المذيعه المصريه تدعى منى العمده اوقفتها
قناه النهار عن التقديم دون الاعلان عن
الاسباب بعد مبالغه العمده كما قال النقاد
في لغه حفيف اوراق الشجر الدافئه
العاصمه الاداريه الجديده تهادي المساحه
دوله سنغافوره
147.000 فدان
في حلقه جديده من برنامجكم هنا الجمهوريه
الجديده النهارده حلقه مليئه بالاخبار
السره وقصص النجاح
المستقبل لك مع عمرو اديب واحمد موسى
وكلهم ستعودين على حصان ابيض وسيشاهد
برامجك الملايين لان زمانك ما مات او على
طريقته
يقول شكسبير لا يعمم الا الاغبياء يعني لا
نستطيع مثلا ان نقول ان النساء السنا
ماهرات في قياده السيارات ف بعضهن يقودن
افضل من بعض الرجال
لفتت فتاه هنديه انذار العالم
بسيطرتها على ثعبان من فئه كبرى الخطره
وحبسته في مستوعب بين بلاستيكي بكل هدوء
وثبات
[موسيقى]
في المقابل شاب ايراني يقال له شهاب ملح
لسعته الكبرى في دماغه وكدا يتوقف قلبه
عندما راى مصادفه في بغداد المغنيه
العراقيه شذى حسون شاهد الفيديو كيف تصدق
شكسبير لا يعمم الا الاغبياء
اخيرا
[موسيقى]
كافي قوم
نائبه بحرينيه اسمها مريم الصائغ تعزز
الكلمات عن صياغه جمله لوصف عنصريتها
الغريبه
اعتبرت ان مهنه محاسب الصندوق في المتاجر
لا تناسب مؤهلاتها العلميه يعني قبل
مريرها رغم انها وظيفه الكثير من
الجامعيين لكن المفاجاه انها تعتبرها مهنه
لا تناسب شكلها
ليش لا يناسب مؤهلاتي العلميه ولا العمليه
ولا حتى سوري شكلي
شو هي المهنه اللي بتنسب شكلك بلا زغره
وهل هناك لائحه شروط تتعلق بالشكل لاي
مهنه ربما مهنه واحده او اثنتان على ابعد
التقدير
وان شاء الله
في الحرم النبوي الشريف دون ان يدري عندما
صوره احدهم وهو يخلع عباءته ليغطي بها
رجلا قيل انه باكستاني
اخيرا برنامج امير الشعراء على احدى
القنوات الاماراتيه تحكمه اللجنه التحكيم
اشتهرت كما تعلمون باخطائها اللغويه برغم
ان وظيفتها تصحيح لغه الشعراء
عثرنا على الحلقه المفقوده فيها هي تتالف
من ثلاثه اعضاء ويجب براي بهيج اي انضم
اليها عضو رابع هو عضو حديث في لجنه تحكيم
مهرجان الظفره للابل ان اؤدي مهام عملي
ان اؤدي ان يؤدي
وان استقلال
وان استقاله
[موسيقى]
ختاما اذا وضعوك على راسي شجره فلا تقطعها
لانك اول من سيقع فانت تتربع على القمه
والاشجار تتساقط من رؤوسها وليس من جذوعها
تماما كالجسد عندما يهوي صاحبه على الارض
فان راسه سيرتطم وربما يتحطم اما القدمان
فلي يتغير عليه ما شيء هما على الارض قبل
السقوط وبعده ولا تعتقد انك ستنجو اذا
استعنت بحطاب في وسط الشجره سيسقطك اولا
وربما ينجو هو ليستغل خطابا عند غيرك بعد
سقوطك الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]